hey guys that is the 13th of May today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching gamespot news here's a bunch of
story that man is known for two things
who penchant for standing on high places
and his dislike of guns fortunately to
ironically address that last one he's
bringing back his trusty anti-gun gun in
a spotlight feature on their forums the
dev revealed that the disruptor anti-gun
gadget from Arkham City will be
returning in our tonight basically it
functions much like a sniper rifle but
only insofar as it features long-range
scopes the disruptor has three charges
per engagement and can be used to jam
enemy weapons as they fire at Batman
using two charges can explode enemy
weapons and you can also use it to rig
weapon crates to shock enemies we try to
arm themselves as well as tag vehicles
for tracking Sony UK have flaunted the
massive world of The Witcher 3 in a new
35 minute gameplay video published on
PlayStation access the video shows a
journey across the witches 3 map from
end to end girls troubles on foot
horseback and even by boat to get to the
main city of novigrad there are also
plenty of map screenshots out in the
wild now for you to get a feel for the
size of the world you can check out
girls traveling adventure of games but
finally Naughty Dog are pretty pleased
with themselves today after sharing the
massive improvements they've made to
their facial animation systems the dev
told games TM that they're now able to
animate face models with between 300 to
500 bones whereas previous song charted
games and the last of us featured closer
to 100 bones thanks to new tech and less
memory restrictions there now also able
to record raw animations at 30 frames
per second making them much smoother
when they translate it into the actual
game they've said it's helping them make
characters show more emotion like having
nathan drake grimace while climbing crap
in uncharted 4 so enjoy the guilt of
making him
in there the studio has said in the past
about their targeting 60 frames per
second for uncharted 4 but won't
sacrifice the overall experience for a
higher framerate lead designer Ricky
cambia said envisioning the next
graphically thin games is difficult but
they will likely keep improving the look
of games as they learn the system's
better he singled out killzone shadow
fall and the order 1886 and some of the
best looking games on any system let me
know down in the comments which game you
think a look spectacular and why you can
add two games but we've got a story on
an amazing Witcher 3 cosplay and
Nintendo's plans 43 that is all the good
stuff that I wanted to tell you about
today but do you remember that I'll have
a bunch more news for you same time
tomorrow